[Musique]
il découvre un peu les problèmes des
français les problèmes du pays
en pleine campagne présidentielle à
quelques mois de la campagne
présidentielle faut être plus
indépendant et pour ça il faut
développer des ressources énergétiques
qui nous permettent d'être indépendant
on a une chance en france c'est qu'on a
un parc nucléaire c'est le retour de
giscard d'estaing on à la fois les
réacteurs nucléaires nous faire croire
que c'est la grande modernité en parler
on à l'avion vert comme on avait les
avions renifleurs et donc à la fin vous
avez des gens qui vous explique qu'il
faut abandonner le nucléaire
qu'il faut arrêter le charbon c'est ce
qu'on fait on ferme de centrales à
charbon et à la fin il reste quoi il
reste la bougie je croyais que le bus de
la police était de protéger la
population n'était pas nécessairement de
posséder des armes pour la tuer parce
que c'est ça la signification en bon
français courant voilà merci lors des
interventions les sapeurs-pompiers sont
victimes quotidiennement de violences
physiques ou verbales sur les dix
dernières années le nombre d'agressions
a augmenté de 2 113 % après après madame
c'est que les policiers sont racistes
les policiers nationaux armés avec des
armes létales tu la population monsieur
lannoy
le lycéen de 18 ans n'a pas été beaucoup
plus loquace face aux juges au moment
d'expliquer pourquoi il a bousculé sa
professeure dans cette vidéo tournée
vendredi dernier
c'est ma faute de a à z j'en ai
conscience je quitte le conseil
municipal parce que je peux pas entendre
des choses comme quoi la police armés
tuent des gens c'est juste pas possible
il vous êtes ignobles vous êtes ignobles
et moi je reste pas à côté de personnes
comme vous l'élève de terminale
professionnelle en seine-et-marne a été
condamné à cinq mois de prison avec
sursis pour son geste nous avons saisi
le conseil scientifique qui nous
recommandent et nous avons décidé de
l'écouté de ne pas toucher aux passani
terre avant au moins le 15 novembre et
ensuite ce projet de loi prévoit la
possibilité de recourir aux différentes
mesures de freinage dont le pass
sanitaire jusqu'en juillet 2022
initialement ce devait être jusqu'au 15
novembre prochain une fois le texte voté
le gouvernement n'aura plus besoin de
consulter le parlement pour actionner le
ou les outils sondage après sondage
l'hypothèse zemmour prend corps
l'écrivain s'imposerait à nouveau face à
ses concurrents au premier tour de la
présidentielle selon ce sondage harris
interactive pour challenge recueillant
entre 17 et 18% à des suffrages on veut
pas un blanc-seing jusqu'au 31 juillet
on veut que le gouvernement
régulièrement reviennent vers nous pour
dire est-ce que c'est utile est-ce que
c'est efficace est ce que ça justifie et
bâtons projet contre projet on va enfin
pouvoir le faire on va arrêter ce chassé
croisé ce jeu de cache-cache où chacun
va à la télévision de son côté des
bâtons
je pense à la commission à trois
mois soit avant qu'ils m'avaient invité
en solitaire
c'est toujours les frissons parce que
donc la poussée et combien
alors je connais pas le montant la
poussée et elle est juste supérieur au
poids clémentine autain fait référence à
ce moment mais certains cadres du
rassemblement national veulent venir
vers nous voulons ouvrir les bras
j'imagine
vous comprenez en regardant ça la
difficulté de maîtriser
en plus ils ont fusé
c'est comme tenir en équilibre en créant
sur votre toit en accélérant violemment
vers le haut et pareil reposer ma chance
finalement même même endroit
m
[Musique]
oh
mais aujourd'hui c'est le souvenir de
star trek du capitaine kirk du petit
écran qui a ressurgi
pour un après-midi la réalité bien plus
émouvante que la fiction
[Musique]